We're crushing our coolest
videos into bite-sized pieces
for your inspiration and entertainment.
I'm Grant Thompson,
and this is King of Random Rewind.
10. SPOT WELDER
9. ONE WAY VALVE
8. MAKING MOLDS
7. RECORDING AT MACH 1
6. BREAKFAST UTENSILS
5. DRAGON BREATH
4. GLASS ARROWHEADS
3. FORTNITE HAMMER
2. CASTING HOLLOW CANDY
1. PENCIL SLINGSHOT
Hey guys, Grant here.
Hope you enjoyed this compilation.
If you would like
to see another one,
just click right up there.
If you want to see another video
that's randomly selected for you,
click down there.
And if you're not
already a subscriber,
just hit the bomb to get in the club.
See you in the next video.